known as the land of fire and ice
Iceland is an island of extremes where
people wage a relentless war against the
elements it's seriously unpredictable
whether it's basically like a battle
zone of different high pressure low
pressure areas anything can happen
dangerous conditions mean people can
find themselves in serious trouble and
in need of rescue but there's a problem
the small country has no army or
government program to help so citizens
form the Icelandic search-and-rescue
team known as Isis are a national
emergency force there every day people
willing to risk their lives to save
others in the worst conditions
imaginable you're going out and the
conditions when everyone else is
supposed to be inside so you have to be
a little bit crazy but in a good way
Iceland is the community of volunteers
that responds to calls for help all year
round in Iceland
I think to take part a nice are you just
have to be willing to put forward the
skills that you have
I sometimes consider a recipe team like
a village we need every kind of person
to make everything work I think it's
kind of amazing because it's all
volunteers we have professors taxi
drivers carpenters plumbers office
workers just name it
911 all kind of people it's very hard to
imagine Iceland without our association
and our teams
Iceland's breathtaking landscape
attracts tourists and adventure seekers
from all over the world but that beauty
can lure people to a false sense of
security the weather conditions can
change faster than anything else you can
have a sunny day and in two minutes its
storm wind rain even snow in fists all
the time
people are just going for a hike and
they're pretty confident that the
mountain that they're going on is not
dangerous have the lower glaciers which
have become quite a popular tourist
attraction and people are going for
walks on these and they are full of
crevasses extremely dangerous
super slippery and then they follow her
and hurt themselves then they have to
rely on certain rescue to come and find
them for average citizens to gain the
skills needed to be part of ice are they
go through a rigorous 18-month training
program they learn mountaineering
climbing and orienteering it takes a
huge skill set but when you can't deal
with any weather then you can go out and
help people
[Music]
across the whole country I think our
teams get to PowerPoint five colors per
day there were people there running from
their own work or the family to join the
team when I get called out we have three
coats its f1 high-priority life in stake
f2 not as high priority and f3 easy
going when you get called out high
priority and you get your text that it
says a child then your heart goes
pounding almost out of your chest and
you run out
I don't didn't say goodbye to my
children or wife I can remember one
called boy I've lost Intel for all I
could think about was my son if he got
lost I would like to have everyone
helping so
a lot of emotions comes up when you get
caught up I'm proud of the unity and the
fact the people are willing to sacrifice
their spare time to help others
[Music]
the feeling that I get when we rescue
someone doesn't have to be me that finds
the person can be another group
searching somewhere else but we're
searching for the same person when
someone gets found you get this wellness
feeling we did something right there are
heroes in in so many ways but in
Icelandic culture we don't do a lot of
hero talk no I'm not a hero I'm just a
part of a team I'm not a hero no aunt is
the normal person I'm very proud of the
Association and what they have
accomplished they've saved a lot of
lives
you
[Music]
you